[Música]
puede ser
en esto decimos rangos de asesinos
porque se había convertido en Algo
bastante chic radical que queda de la
realidad
un modismo destinado a Teresa en el momento
Había encontrado
porque es Excepto que apegarse a una sola A
nivel mundial y que Assino y el
consigna del Partido totalmente mal entendida
Democrático
que gritó en la Vuelta del Fascismo
en Italia entonces se nos da que
la coalición que enfatizo es una
condición de Grecia central e
Hermanos de Italia es una fiesta
Conservador tiene hermanos dentro
de Italia a las personas que un
fanático del fascismo Como tiene dentro del
Partido Demócrata es
tiene gente que de hecho después de anarquista
del comunismo cae
absolutamente decisivo que
esta coalición
extremista y fascista y yo estaba sentado
democracia democracia a través de
scoderes
ok, básicamente somos um
de las fiestas en las que entra la fiesta
El movimiento oftalmólogo es democrático 5
Las estrellas tienen
esta grandísima situación que no
Son absolutamente ricos en esto último.
cuatro cinco meses Es una situación que
en Italia
es la primera crisis creo es que italia
si es con quien es italia
creciente
película de la segunda guerra mundial
con maxima victoria direccion politica
magia política es que los melones en el
movimiento social Movimento Sociale fue
el partido fascista que personificó
en 1947 entrando
Prácticamente en el Parlamento italiano
el lugar cuando
Noventa seca, sin embargo, expresamente estos
manos limpias Grecia se rindió y
si se fusiona con
Forza Italia y el movimiento del partido
Berlusconi que egano la seleccion de
tengo que subir
de-dertino anoche eh la salsa que
ser Hermanos de Italia que hasta el último
lección
este voto e injertos y leccion le dan
hacia
25,6%
Social ya pertenece en el mes de
Octubre